[Music]
here we go again
sony have revealed the free games we'll
receive as playstation plus subscribers
for the month of february 2021.
like usual we can download these from
the first tuesday of the month which
this time
is the second of february you ready
let's do this
on the ps5 is a new exclusive game
coming straight to ps plus
this is destruction all stars a
multiplayer destruction derby
smash-a-thon
with more than meets the eye 16
champions from around the world compete
to be the ultimate all-star as their
vehicles battle it out
if you've played twisted metal you'll
know the basics here each character has
a ride which performs differently
both in durability and speed and of
course unique abilities
like invisibility the quirk of this game
is going out on foot
i know that sounds insane in a vehicular
combat game but by surviving long enough
a new vehicle becomes available and if
that fails we can always grab another
person's car by performing
a takeover there hasn't been any preview
content for the game which means every
single one of us will be a complete noob
on day one destruction all stars is here
on ps plus throughout february and march
and remember if you don't have a ps5 but
you do have ps
plus you can add this game to your
library using the playstation
app so it's there when you move over to
ps5 and in case you're wondering
destruction all stars will always
require an active ps plus subscription
to be accessible
now the only thing to do is to pick a
character let the battle begin
the next game is available on both ps4
and ps5
and it's a beauty control ultimate
edition
this is the full game plus all the
expansions
control is an action-focused
third-person adventure game
with insane shootouts and quite
challenging puzzles
all besides the backdrop of the
unknowing world of the federal bureau of
control
our character jessie has abilities major
abilities like telekinesis
throwing rubble and items at enemies
using the power of her mind
she's also pretty handy with more
grounded firearms over the course of the
game we uncovered jesse's past as well
as the dimension hopping entity that
intends to wipe out the human race
the expansions add greatly to the story
and the understanding of the world
it's a really thought out game if you
haven't played control i beg you to do
so
both ps4 and ps5 versions are here for
you
control averaged 8.5 out of 10 across
professional reviewers back in 2019
and finally another beauty of a game on
the ps4
this is concrete genie a unique tale of
a bullied child named ash
who uses their artwork as a coping
mechanism but little did we know
those pieces of art come to life and
assist ash throughout their adventure
the city is dark and lonely but by the
time ash is finished
neon paint will be everywhere concrete
genie has additional modes for psvr
users too
making the artwork you create even more
visceral
i think i know what you're going to draw
first you dirty individual you
concrete genie is another playstation
exclusive which released back in october
2019 so it's a little over a year old
so that's the games for february 2021.
what do you reckon
for me this is a 10 out of 10 month i'm
really impressed a brand new multiplayer
title
a game of the year contender from 2019
and a game
like no other let me know your thoughts
in the comments i'm adam from
playstation grenade
i'll see you next time